tu viens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
doudou je suis né sur une belle île dans
une petite cabane déjà toute petite
fille je m j'ai des grosses bananes
grosse banane je suis vraiment la nana
il y en a pas de comme moi il paraît
qu'anama toutes les filles ont le Cuba
le Cuba toi tu es vraiment une fille
comme il faut hein oui mais j'ai un gros
défaut je veux un homme qui du fric je
m'en fous qu'il soit beau je suis une
nigresse Afrique oui elle a un grand
défaut elle ve un homme qui est fr elle
s'en fout qu'il soit fa c'est
F si vous voyez mon grand frère c'est de
moi tout le contraire on dirait un vrai
zombie il a la tête Hati Haïti non pas
Haïti le pays hein Haïti le monstre la
gauche bébé de kimotte oui Haïti F de
maison si vous voyez ma copine complexé
du soir au matin elle danse très mal la
pquine on dirait un vrai boudin vrai
Bouin un Bouin créole bien sûr un Bouin
créole bien sûr tu es vraiment une fille
comme il faut toi alors oui mais j'ai un
gros défaut je veux un homme qui est du
FR je m'en fous qu'il soit beau je suis
uneresse à oui
[Musique]
est allez pous allez pous pas trop fort
mon ou alors
[Musique]
qui
quel est le fruit que je préfère doudou
on ne sait pas quel est le fruit que je
préfère doudou on ne sait pas quel est
le fruit que je préfère doudou on ne
sait pas quel est le fruit que tu
préfère je donne ma Mang chat vraiment
une fille comm il fautasour et tout oui
mais j'ai un gros défaut je suis un
homme qui est du fruit je m'en fous
qu'il soit beau je suis une graisse
fruit oui elle a un
un homme qui est elle sen qu'il soit
beau
[Musique]
c'est attendez les copains attendez
attendez il y a Thierry Le l il a plein
de pognons il y a aussi philiip B il a
plein de doll allez viz les copines on
va danser avec lui la B allez-ce qu'il
ve danser avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la qu'
so
qu' allez vasy
B
allez allez
allez salut les copains les copines on
revoit on
[Musique]
revoit